if you leave Khan now you take away the
biggest part of Khan oh no baby please
tell us what is the WoW oh you can set
it on different things it's aliens I was
this no pod casts on the way it down
here and you can drop it now tell me now
you switch it Kunduz me now and it turns
out that's not a sheet which makes it
look like he's bigger room it's actually
a bigger ruler yeah another organ had on
the blink-182 guy yeah
looked on shorter lon or whatever the
[__] his name is Solange is the one who
say it ain't so
and why I miss you massive conspiracy
theorist and his lab age he started a
company and he claims he's got loads of
secret government officials working with
him and that he's got all this
information on UFOs and really he's just
sitting around in a room all day
reciting I miss you know that over and
over again
Morgan was you do in the audience ago
Rogan was question him and he was like I
can't really talk about that and he
supposed to said that about ten names
that means you don't have a [__] clue
doesn't it gets good guests on us nobody
we don't need a guest no but it's
annoying like not not being funny I've
got to have a little word here with the
audience you know in the first sort of
six months to a year you lot
digging in deep sending as loads of
guest suggestions now it's just like
Anthony Joshua I'm not being funny as
much as I think one day maybe it's not
as easy as just given the heavyweight
chump in the world to call me like all
right well this will be out after his
next fight let's hope he's you still
have you
smash the guy out in two seconds cuz he
will but the point is it's very hard to
get people who are constantly must have
nipped I need you lot to help me we need
some small what Brian saying is we need
some small kooky people to fill in the
gaps we have drug dealers drug takers
drug takers bring them bring them
together ex bankers successful high-end
musicians yeah touring artists the point
is I need your [__] help write x AK c
drive let's go see blue tick now on
twitter and i still haven't managed to
use it for any one of them success so
just tell me some good people that go
after and ideally this is key Cat Deeley
not not her not her they have to be in
London or being able to get a London for
the day so well that's not ideal that's
that's a prerequisite to being on the
podcast you have to be in you have to be
in London on the day then you have to be
able to make it to the unless you want
to fly us somewhere beautiful yeah if
you want to fly you're satisfied good to
see you help us so pretty content all
the time Yeah right like the video and
subscribe as well while I'm away you're
for that adverts over thanks Harry and
then data bits over so the moon landings
happened right what the moon landings
happened do you believe the moon
landings didn't happen just speaking
about conspiracy theorists alright so
we're gonna do the is this the
conspiracy no no it's not the no but I
just want to do the moon landings it's
sort of a little a preview all right in
my mind I come home in my opinion moon
sucks I know that was actually a song
about a NASA scientist that's that guy
is literally tried to say that is
actually a song about in that size it
say it ain't so I will not go turn the
lights on the fake lights which they
thought were the Sun carry me home home
being probably Houston Texas song about
a conspiracy theory um hashtag respect
the conspiracy theorists nag respect the
bed did we go of the moon is that what
we're starting with
but yes no we haven't been and nor has
anybody else people since the last time
they were in the 70s or 60s they started
that started in 60s and 70s someone then
since then they were like well that's
enough for that Explorer go back why go
back when the technology is improved and
we can probably learn a lot more about
the moon it's just a big hustle but we
know all about room we know it's made of
cheese we know that the people there are
sort of scared of us so we don't need it
all Souza's I don't have a [__] clue
whether or not we went to the moon at
all and I don't does but what I do know
is there is footage out there of a man
stepping foot on a surface in that's one
small step for man one giant leap for
mankind anyway to be honest with you
could be anywhere the photographs the
videos could be anywhere I would have no
idea I watched a video the other day
which said it would have been very
difficult back then to recreate the
conditions of the moon because of all of
the lighting you wouldn't you would need
it exactly like a massive fan of
lighting very difficult to recreate the
conditions of the Moon on a on a movie
set but get into the actual moon and
getting up there using a rocket and all
of that no problem it's not no problem
but some people are just saying it was
no problem they got there yeah some
people are just saying it probably would
have been cheaper easier and more
efficient to actually go to the moon
than to stand around going wait how can
we make this look like them I mean
obviously if I sit here with the
documents as Alex Jordan says we have
the documents Alex Jones is a null and
void he's now employed I was just saying
if we had the documents it might make
life a lot easier but you're asking is
off the top of my head now to either say
whether or not the footage which we
don't have was was real or faked but you
know read it a lot well there's there's
some there's some things which do raise
an eyebrow and you know that's a red
flag like what what hmm what the flag
for one thing red and white and blue
flag that was flapping as if wind was on
the moon now I know that you've got a
million debunk as out there but just
generally speaking I am NOT a scientist
this from just a common sense man's
point of view
if space is a vacuum then why is the
flag flappin and why are there so many
different light sources in these
photographs I don't get it
there are a lot of light sources so on
the moon there's only one light source
the Sun why when a man takes a
photograph and the Sun is behind the man
and it's in a straight line the man
should then be a silhouette because the
Sun is behind us it's pretty bright
years and he isn't a silhouette he is
reflected and lit up perfectly and
interestingly there's just a lot of
astronauts who've come up with very
conflicting stories so we didn't one
said open the Rope there we didn't see
any stars and then when he was
interviewed when he got out he was like
oh we noticed all the stars looked
amazing and there's just a lot of dodgy
stories and that and also when they've
been collared these guys and I know this
doesn't mean anything but I just find it
an interesting halter and just punches
them I think no I think it's a very
interesting story generally because the
moon London was the biggest success in
our history as a species well it's one
of many good things but getting that far
outside of our atmosphere and that we it
was amazing Janome and crazy and yet it
might have all been [__] and I just
find that interesting none of them have
all been approached with Bibles sway
down on the sucker Bible that you did
this so none of them will do that
they're on all of the you can you can
youtube search that you know you need to
find atheist no one not really got me
was a little documentary called
a funny thing happened on the way to the
moon where at one point where they are
said to be very close to the moon right
and the moon they're having a bit of a
well they're having the recording
session and they say that they've got
like a lens Oh they've got a lens over
the window on the spacecraft and they
take that lens away and you say that the
earth is a lot closer it's a bit like
you know when you have a magnifying
glass you spent the other way around it
makes it look further away they've done
that and and you just ask yourself why
would you want that
earth to appear further away than what
it was if you want trying to act like
you're closer to the moon than you
actually are so maybe you can see
everything because the lens makes it so
you can see more I mean maybe they're
looking for a great view who knows but
the point is is at that time when they
recorded that I think and I'm literally
going off of memory from years and years
ago watching this they were supposed to
be a lot closer at the moon and one of
the main things that a lot of scientists
to be is the Van Allen radiation belt as
well yeah a lot of people talk about the
radiation and could we as humans go pass
through that without frying yeah you
know and I've got a [__] clue but the
fact that all of the moon landings
happened under Richard Nixon's private
presidency and what a shady [__]
he was and the fact that Russia had
actually had a lot more success than
America
in terms of building spacecrafts and all
that and then all that's shown in one
day boom America I've done it you know
as unusual those Russian never never
went either but they never claimed that
Americans didn't end on the moon weirdly
well they have done since I think Putin
has come out and said some things since
that but what what I think's interesting
is just the fact that nobody other than
America during the Richard Nixon
presidency has gone up there like who
else is going India well to be fair
India the reason I saying there is not
to mock them but because they have built
their own own spacecraft
yeah I mean at the end of the day Korea
no I won India I could have a few
curries probably fought me way to the
moon right cuz you probably would I
although you put the entire anyway it's
just in human history we meet the radio
we make the TV who made a spacecraft
omit the internet iPhones everything is
constantly growing getting better a
better a better apart from one thing
what space travel or the moon and and
we've never been any further with a
human onboard a spacecraft
yeah and and when you look at that when
you look at the the footage it just
looks so like rinky-dink to be honest it
looks like meaning you could not get
together what the footage well now yeah
but do you think part problem is we're
looking back now am I going with
cameras yeah and it's sort of more like
actually if anything now when I look
back at it and I'm questioning it I
think to myself how hard it is just for
people to get a signal with the
technology we've got now which I think
everyone agrees is better than in the
70s from a footman on board an aeroplane
and yet they were broadcasting live from
the moon and it amazes us children I
mean I mean to be fair what you've got
nowadays is probably very different to
what you have back then they'll be able
to vary a lot better know you would have
oh yeah but maybe also on if not many
people are broadcasting from the moon so
I'd imagine it is maybe it's probably
easier to get that there's another thing
that was quite challenges when they sped
up a lot of the footage with the
astronauts
bouncing across the surface yeah they
did look a little bit like there was
like like it was just like slowed down
on zip lines and [__] like that like it
didn't look it just looked weird do you
know what I mean it looked like they
were there just the footage of being
sort of slowed down and stuff do you
think I mean it's just the way it
appeared literally once again no [__]
clue but the footage does look a bit
dodgy yeah it sort of problem isn't it
because it's the same as when people
talk about like 9/11 conspiracies and
stuff they they highlight like the plane
and things like I met let's draw an
outline around the plane well yeah but
you're literally a man with photos on
but for me though like like I said
before everything is evolving and yet we
just literally went to the moon for a
few years and then nothing ever grew
from that like you'd have thought we'd
went alright well we've done that now
we'll move on we'll go further and
further in in space travel grown grow it
never grew and that's partly strange
that's partly economic wasn't it they've
spent a fuckton on NASA I mean the
actual the numbers they spend on NASA in
my opinion or an absolute disgrace and
it and what interests me is one one one
thing that conspiracy theorists have
said which I am inclined to think that
there may be truth in is imagine the
amount of money you can all that were
use not a NASA Jeremy where it goes who
[__] knows
general I mean we're well the party the
spread like trillions on NASA in that
and what did they got to show for it
one one one moon London for in fifty
years ago and the other Apollo missions
no like and Apollo 13 is a great film I
mean Tom Hanks is a great actor even
amongst gravity not really angry why not
do you know his sons a rapper he heard
about this his sons like a gangster
rapper about his sons like a wannabe yes
wait he's not my son too much what Saul
doesn't amongst team West but he's older
too much much older than dirt I once had
a friend who his dad loved Tim Westwood
yeah and I got in the back of his dad's
car and he was listening you know
remember west would you stop that Friday
night show quite I think it's probably
like maybe eight or nine at night and he
used to be like yo baby this sliding we
does that capital extra or something
some [__]
some ears and they still gone some [__]
global radio stuff yo baby capital extra
yo and I was a bit like Tim Westwood
[__] isn't he and it's that stop the car
turn around to me and went yeah but he
knows his stuff and my friend was like
don't embarrassment do you know that his
dad was a vicar or something yeah priest
well I mean my first day in in London
proper day in London when I saw a mask
I've started working here properly I
went to a burger place yeah and I've
just saw getting served by this girl and
helps to be a black girl very pretty
black girl and I was good-looking girls
do you ever seen no not any life well
they have them in Newcastle thank God
not enough of them do you know anyway
not complaining underwear them and
people people can go with mine I'm just
saying I appreciate you know pretty
bloody appreciate all people pretty
black girls I like pretty black girls
it's fine you don't say that on you I'm
I always say that yeah alright God
anyway it's like pretty white girls I
mean yeah but anyway the point is how's
it happened I got chatting to her and I
was a surprise and a man from the North
talking someone in London who feels very
awkward about
scenario she didn't feel awkward at all
she was bloodier than the accent
friendly that's all it was she thought
Tim my switz gon bit weird seriously
those turned out should [__] Tim
Westwood yeah I mean that's not a small
number of people but she was I was like
how old is she was I 80 in a wine hit
named work with an I know a job she was
18 land and I was like how do like what
and I can tell she was so embarrassed by
it like yes so embarrassed that she told
a complete stranger
no her dated sort of been talking about
for a little while and that we'd gotten
quite friendly really you know just know
she gave you the fries and you never
[__] in West man what fact Thanks okay
absolutely ya know and I was like
hitting the sound effects bar rewind
like you must be like 50 and like Mesa
[__] 18 year old girls like Fair Play
only 50 cent used to love him yeah I
think I think ya Rattlers just like any
DJ who plays the music too much puts a
weird guy though yeah he's I mean he
seems he seems nice and very friendly he
wants to be something he's not let's
link Westwood clear the problem with for
Tim Westwood is he looked fine but he
looms so all the time he's always over
you so it's always like yo now when you
bought your kind here it was whack and I
don't mean in a good way but we've
picked it out and you're like cool he's
like look at those wheels lizard pimp my
what righted me hmm would you ever do
pimp my ride
nope why I died when I was a kid I
really want to see a pimp my ride
I'm a submit when exhibit was the horse
died I think everyone watched like it
was funny wasn't it yeah pimp my ride UK
was West wooden was total hit my ride us
was was exhibit yeah
a few people have been asking us to have
that YouTube guy who's the one who did
ksi score up and all of that
he saw Janna mais yeah he does YouTube
cause yeah yeah don't know what we would
talk about how many cars have you done
Yanni you'd be working much many
cartoons Bonnie what's your favorite car
got say probably the Lamborghini baby
every us not yeah he seems like a nice
guy
one thing about the moon-landing one
thing about the moon landings is from
Westwood
how would you hide it in a company of
hundreds of thousands of employees and
go by the way we did go to the moon
don't tell anyone we didn't well and and
just try and imagine because obviously
this isn't a theory I'm literally
thinking of this on the spar theory but
they're on very old-fashioned computers
right yeah I think we can all agree on
that but price as long as the numbers
are coming through that should be coming
through as if they're on the moon and
the people who are analyzing the data
are just getting the data that they
should be getting if that was on the
moon they're gonna be none the wiser and
as long as what's on the screen looks
like it's on the moon and as long as
you're broadcasting and everything looks
right at that point in time we never
even had diehard one hadn't even been
made at this point you know I mean
people are even used to action in films
that could replicate that sort of little
question who's then putting the data
into the computers that then come back
out of the computers I'm pretty sure
there'd be someone capable of doing that
considering someone made a computer like
that that was able to read this so what
you'd need to do is you need to find
someone who's as clever as the
scientists who think who you're trying
to trick into thinking that they've sent
a rocket to the moon which is then
landed and needs to take off on backs
where you're gonna trick those clever
people into thinking that all of this
not is happening because you need people
who are just as clever behind the scenes
to make computers that'll trick them
into thinking that those numbers are
coming through I mean this is just a
theory I've come up
but in general numbers coming through
these like later ones and zeros well I
thought that's what would it come
through I think that the way people
debunk theories and literally I'm little
sitting yeah pissing around with you and
[__] podcast but the point is the way
I debunk theories is to be bunk to
ridicule the questions that are being
asked and a lot of people do that rather
than actually trying to answer the
initial questions okay and the initial
questions are right this footage doesn't
look right for a star the fact that
nobody's and all the questions I've
raised so far and they're in there I
haven't even got the footage in front of
us I could probably ask about ten more
so rather than ridicule the questions
I'm asking how about let's just say it
does this footage look right yeah and
for me when you look at the moon landing
footage there's just a lot of things
that don't add up
either you've probably that of course if
some of the questions are of course
stupid questions and then it's hard not
to really kill them and people get
people who ask questions and when you
make fun of them or you go that's a bit
of a silly question isn't it they go
well don't ridicule I'm only asking a
question you know like I don't know I
don't think any of the questions I've
raised are silly though so what but I'm
only saying you're saying then they
would have made a machine that tricked
the scientists into thinking I'm [__]
literally I'm making that up off the
[__] top of my head I'm sure there's
somebody who's done a lot more research
into this than me who was a better
theory than I do what do you think the
government get from pretending to land
on the moon a lot of [__] money the
trillions that have gone in a NASA for a
start when you think of how much poverty
there is in America and you think of
what they could have done with the true
well not even well literally talk about
trillions trillions like there's a lot
of reason to [__] to justify why we need
all this money and that would have been
the main reason and then your you know
better than Russia we got there first
and all Russia
why did Russia think for some the space
race was quite a big do you I mean you
did your revision on this button there
didn't you I'll of this face the space
race was a big deal wasn't it what it
was all about that competition and that
I think seems a bit silly it would be
I'd be like I just
it's easier to have a space race than an
arms race hmm then you'd have to shoot
each other and you can still keep both
of your economies going well maybe it
was a big big economic trip to keep both
economies going and America wanted
Soviet rule because it gave them
something to fight together see I'm not
even saying that we didn't go to the
moon I'm just in the footage of [__]
right you know I mean we may have lied
and say that but ultimately if you
actually wanted Alex Jones as theories
oh yeah is that what I'm just saying
gone Alex Alex Terry's been known fraud
one of Alex Jones's theories is that he
C says that we did land on the moon but
that they couldn't broadcast from them
would say the shot footage I was
pre-recorded to be played around the
same time so we did land on the moon
don't know why didn't they then take a
camera to the moon and then when they
came back so does it well no they don't
even have to do herself it didn't have
to be a selfie time you can just film
the other guy yeah Phil silver guy so
why do you that's a bit of a [__]
conspiracy theory isn't it Alex
I mean to me if it's probably one or the
other isn't it where they did or we
didn't and the footage is either real or
it isn't
well yeah but surely the way to debunk
Alex's theory there is you go Alex why
didn't they just shoot it while they're
on the moon and go you'll only have to
wait a couple of days because we're
gonna bring the footage back and when we
land we'll show you the footage ever not
everyone on the planet was going no we
want to see it live when we land on the
moon I think there's something about
Americans thought I'm with the
razzmatazz that it had to be a
broadcasted live I don't know why I mean
I'm in agreeance for you but I don't
think the American public was demanding
it though they weren't sort of going oh
it's like x-factor but it remember it
it's the biggest accomplishment in the
minds of the people at the time in human
history and there are many middle
Americans going
they should be broadcast on live TV I
think it was a massive deal and if you
look at the viewing figures I bet you
that buck that up ya know but only after
they were told this will be on TV there
were very few middle Americans who work
in [__] Kansas who were working in the
fields going tell you what if I don't
see this bloody moon lying to my days
over I've got no idea yeah I mean I
really don't know what the farmers were
thinking amazing I got one on the
podcast at some point you know
I wouldn't mind going to middle amount
I'd love to go to like that southern
part of America meet the people I was I
don't know you've got on very well with
I think I would I think most of this guy
like me more than you so honey say that
I don't know if that's always the case I
think actually when you meet people
people just tend to get on anyway yeah
when you go to a place people are lovely
I would have liked to have had the
university well know when I watched
those like high school movies and that
when people got Union that I was think I
probably would have enjoyed that you do
enjoy not in this currently but going to
an American Union live in that proper
life hold your books you would you have
had the funny cutoff sweaters and the
pocket protectors no I would like to be
like college footballer yeah - not I
mean that's kinda llege NFL yeah that's
college yeah college ball / yeah what
you would have done basketball
no no NFL NFL that's not hardly I'm
tailor-made for that although probably a
bit sloth at this point of my life but
you know yeah but back then you would
have been I would have been a [__]
animal raw power mmm
there was a guy in London a year ago he
went to NFL went through the whole
drafting process then came back got shot
in London couldn't do it [__] at home
hmm
but still alive lucky to be last shot
yeah shot nine times I think he was I
don't know if it was nine times or if
I'm actually complaining that was 50
céntimos you actually watch get Richard
I try very same day oh now you can't
remember which is which I'd like to get
$0.50 on the pod car like 50 cent he
seems like a nice guy
it's a mudhole he just well put a 50
cent Tim Westwood the link does I dress
good I think the best the best thing
about the moon-landing was it gave
people a story to tell for a while
yeah and it was sort of a story I was
thinking about stories the other day we
were supposed to I want to talk about
this last Friday but we're the last day
we record I want to talk about like
stories do you remember any stories as a
kid what's your favorite story that you
knew as a kid like what kinda Jack and
Jill
you know did you not like for instance I
was just so my dad was in town and I was
looking up with him true meanings of
stories Jack and Jill a man and a
prostitute really yeah
I don't it was dumped he was a cannon
well that fell off the wall and then
they couldn't and it sort of makes sense
when it's cannon you think why change
Humpty Dumpty to an egg yeah it's
actually good as a cannon yeah don't
make it an egg all the king's horses and
all the king's men why would all the
King's horse and all the king's men want
to put an egg together wasn't much of a
reader at school no but you can be my
listener
I tried listening to an audio book made
by youtuber Lillian it didn't end very
well who's the youtuber just named them
who was it wasn't very good
was it so Ella no what was it he said it
was a woman rather than a coin with the
other day he said it was a woman let's
just move on right
the point was was it awkward reading so
and then we went to the shop you know
when you listen to someone read like for
me I want an audio booth got a scanners
who almost feel like you're talking to
me as in you're telling me the story as
if it off the top of your head and and
reciting it from memory whereas this was
like and then I almost had a very bit
like you know looking here them reading
the words and it's like today junior you
know yeah what you do is make them
retake it at that point clearly not
because it's out now for 10 pounds 10
pounds you spent and already oh yeah I'm
really because I'm considering one day
doing one and I thought I want to see
what these are like you know if you go
to I'd be much better audible you can
always get a free audiobook from
audible.com out so another thing that's
illegal and got both of brocco bombers
books fantastic he's tired but just get
over the line you were almost falling
asleep aren't you I don't know what's
wrong with us why don't you take a
little now come on the Brit have a
little breath right back
Brian please don't swear oh I'm gonna
get more content for the Bears gay bears
Instagram so I'm in the hot seat hmm
Laurent McKenna welcome back to con cast
on today's show we're talking
Constantine con this camera or that one
but they're not recording away they're
recording are they yeah today we're
talking con cast con it's the biggest
event of the year for all con fans out
there some people wanted to call it
commie vlog camera
some people want it's call it comic-con
Comicon team and that could work
because you are also you're a socialist
I don't know what that word means Europe
Soviet ex-soviet no no I was born after
the Soviet Union was dissolved dissolved
yes right possibly the month after yeah
Wow
see your mom I'm sort of keeping her
legs closed just - what's your favorite
Russian star you know any Russian
stories I don't know any Russians you
must have some and I will have been told
don't know what [__] I have there's
some really great rush old Russian films
I'd love for you to watch great what
about the Russian stories [__] you
don't need me to tell you they're great
he's not gonna [__] one Russian woman
he's gonna [__] the whole stadium gone
Russian you must know a Russian nursery
rhyme do you want me to tell you in
Russian you can you tell me a Russian
nursery actually don't know any oh [__]
off what if I translate one sure Russian
nursery
antoshka antoshka
what does that mean ah dude I'm gonna
find you the song and ah ah wait no wait
is it is like a potato ochco well
no meant to be resting rest up [__] now
you want to get involved in the podcast
[Music]
yeah okay sing along okay sing along
it's about a kid who doesn't want to do
any work oh oh they made it it made a
nurse around back on we weren't in the
audio Amy's name is antoshka antoshka
Antonito okay antoshka antoshka yep do
it got a thorough score let's go dig
potatoes so they're like come on come on
let's go to work he pops out from Elly's
like clearly be leaf bloody daddy Slick
Rick we wasn't taught this nobody taught
me this so like I'm not gonna bother
doing it right that speaks for itself
the up his ass art ass No
[Music]
Anthony Anthony they saying come on come
work with us
come on Anthony come boys and potatoes
yeah and he's like nobody ever taught me
that like we don't learn that in school
I've got the iPhone and so I don't need
to exactly yeah
and then by the end of the song what
happens is they cook the potatoes right
and the pans already and I eat it and
then antoshka is like I'm ready now
yeah like oh sorry like yeah [__] buddy
yeah yeah should have helps us from the
beard and does God know yeah go away so
there's a big message in that yeah it's
if you don't put the work in in the
beginning you don't serve the boiled
potatoes in the end antoshka so we're
gonna do emails just because sometimes
just have one of those bad weeks tumblr
you have a bad week and then I have to
have a bad week with I'm having a bad
way personal life bollocks
and behind the scenes a lot going on and
I'm just [__] wrecked yeah to be
honest but what I do like is sharing
about house [__] other people's
lifestyle because then it makes me feel
that they're so on with it know that I
actually liked helping people don't get
a bit of a buzz if what you've seen so
far hasn't been as and my normal
enthusiasm but just people pisses off at
this point of me life you know I mean
and I'm losing the enthusiasm to
tolerate to tolerate people's [__]
in me life I might make a change
g'day chaps
I've got an issue at hand girls thinks
girls think I'm a decidedly a yeah
decently attractive person with a decent
personality he's like on the word decent
yeah I do submit and that's got me in a
bit of a conundrum
there's a girl in a country where I used
to live that I only met recently but
he's very attractive and is down to shag
well I'm still a virgin so this will be
part pretty big thing for me however
where I live currently there is a cute
ish girl with a great personality and I
could potentially start a relationship
with she has feelings for me too but we
aren't dating or anything additionally I
visit where I used to live regularly so
I'm not sure how I should proceed
can you clear this up cause I'm
he's got two girls in two different
locations where he is regularly he's
saying how should he proceed if he and I
know it's genuinely really a real email
from a guy who's saying as two girls
that attracted to him in two different
locations what should he do well this
came just 30 minutes ago well this is
the thing I've just put the soap this
was hot off the press yeah this is a
fresh problem Brian you shut it out can
I just say it were galley as we're gonna
call him [__] them both right short
sharp replies today I mean let's be
honest what if what if you were young
lad you haven't you haven't done
anything yet it's totally still getting
underway what if he wants to remain
faithful he hasn't got a girlfriend if
one of them becomes a girlfriend then by
all means you know what I mean be a
one-woman man but until that point comes
and Joey it's my recommendation okay I
don't me Jack it off by the way I don't
know if we've added little oh I'm a 16
year old boy call me whatever I don't
mind okay whatever that has just
recently come out of a two-year
relationship he's 16 and he had a
two-year relationship the reason we
split up I'm not opposed no you haven't
of how controlling she was and didn't
let me have any friends well since I
broke up with her what a [__] things
have become a lot better for me my
social life has changed dramatically we
go to the same school and share a locker
okay we spoke to each other since the
breakup and tried to tell each other how
we feel about it
bad idea that's when things got out of
control
she was stalking my Instagram seeing who
I followed since I broke up with her was
sending me messages on snapchat saying
how she doesn't want me to be happy and
one day at school got but a doll in my
locker with a bracelet and I got a
bracelet I got her wrapped around its
neck and hung it from the top of the
locker as if it had hung itself what a
lovely whipping is he says as if as if
he's had hug itself and I thought hey
you've almost ironically what do you
think I should do should I confront
and try to talk it out here's a little
bit of this guy's a sensitive guy here's
a tip for this guy right in life there
are some women out there and the lads
don't know what I'm on about when I say
this who there's someone out there whose
mission it is in life to make every man
that they meet extremely unhappy and
you've just happened to meet one very
very early Jelani but as men we've all
had them
some women it's their purpose and what
they start to do was they make out when
you're arguing with him that you know
it's it's a debatable problem you know
is it year was it me no it was women
like this it's always her and with any
man that she meets she will make him
miserable so just get the [__] away as
quick as you can't don't speak though I
don't talk though I don't message ah
she's a lock away I don't care just get
a new locker keep the [__] away from
Aamir because women like that bring
nothing but unhappiness to every man in
their wake and equally there are some
men out there that do the same to women
yeah well basically what you're saying
is there are psychos out there who
haven't yet found out how to have a
healthy relationship and never will and
don't need a lot don't not bring in the
advice I would give is don't be the
person who thinks that you can make them
you can't changer you can't fix her you
come on healer stop wasting your time
don't waste yours of your life don't
waste your time I mean you're already a
voice inside my head I miss you that's
blink-182 that don't don't whistle I've
tried to heal someone if someone's a
[__] and they step always going to be
a [__] I miss you this one comes from
Fenchurch we're gonna call him Donald
Donald Church sorry to give you another
relationship problem but I guess that's
just tough [__] isn't it well yes we go
by the way Donald we know how to answer
your emails basically I've been in an
online relationship with a girl for two
years god I did backwards image searches
when we first started talking to see if
she was real and they came back with no
results so I thought all was okay well
it was all good until a week ago
all was good until a week ago I
discovered the person who she had been
using the pictures for on Instagram or
caught fish so the face of the person
that I fell in love with has been a lie
for the last two years however I fell in
love with anyone you loved could how you
fell in love with the concept however
the girl I loved oh the guy I've been
talking to his real face is actually
still pretty good but I'm hurt by this
whole experience as I was led first I
was late for so long as the girl he
thought was hot it was like an eight or
a nine and then the girl that he's
actually in taught was more like a six
or a seven would like to your girl's
thoughts as I'm something pretty
different than the usual hi I'm 13 and I
like this girl in my class [__]
honestly you're in exactly the same boat
as those you are with all of the love if
anything you've had a two-year
relationship with a girl and not Skype
that you are pathetic that is one you
should always Skype someone early on
early on yeah the first two weeks if you
think that this is a real person and
that you've got a crush FaceTime Skype
whatever just just get them on a camera
and say this is a real person
but anyway turns out the girl you've
been wanting to isn't actually who you
thought it was but the one that she is
pretty in a way I'm sort of jealous
because there's many times I've been in
relationships and thought I could do
with a bit of a change yeah but not a
full change just a body and face tree
you got that Sam saw congratulations
suddenly living the dream you ungrateful
prick your advice enjoy enjoyed the
change right is the spice of life she
did still lie oh she's a lion lunatic
but he's the type of guy around with the
lying lunatic but he's the type of guy
hashtag Langley he's the type of guy
they got two years not even FaceTime in
and just take away served
you certainly [__] yourself really
there yeah an employer salt yeah yeah
congratulations you played yourself well
done well done
Donald you [__] yourself and the
country sorry
I'm a 16 year old in my first year at
college call me whatever I'm gonna call
you
Curtis me and this girl have been
flirting at parties and generally both
showing interest and 100% up for being
sexual me to kiss me to pal I'm a
hundred percent what I go on and I go I
literally I'm in the mirror I'm like yes
put me share splash of it and then I'm
hundred percent up for being section and
I'm now you in the mirror you guys
actually ready you're going to yourself
98 99 100
ready let's go guys just so that you
guys know I'm feeling hundred percent
sexual tonight oh god what is he on a 95
that's what I'm wondering I mean it's
all good to go I just wanna let you know
I'm 90 percent wanting this that's
exactly how it and becoming a thing this
guy I think this guy's currently sort of
like an I do a full meal podcast [__]
yeah because it's funny isn't it however
this girl is very quiet and shy and one
just around me or when not hammered but
still shows interest in me when not
hammered I mean shy girls can some
things be the best Fox you know why
would that be
they're a little bit more unsure of
themselves and they're not as confident
but in in that in that insecurity is
someone who sort of wants you to tell
them everything to do so when you get
them into bed they'll just do everything
you are let's just be honest though this
guy's 16 he's probably not particularly
sexually what I'm saying is I mean dawn
discounters just because she hasn't got
a lot of confidence who hasn't been in a
situation where they've gotten down they
just thought I'm a hundred percent into
just being I just want to be sexual I
was gonna be a sexual guy yeah and the
girl turns and she says sorry but as a
percentage and he goes well 100% but oh
yeah well I I was close to her I'm now a
hundred percent - yeah so uh she's ready
yeah
it sounds like she's a keeper go for it
go for it and also the better you know
someone the better relationship we can
have if she's shy just go for it and
worries me there was some shy girls who
say nothing you know like girls who are
a little bit of like a mute yes you know
what I mean by that like same client
sometimes when you first meet a girl
yeah you think yourself she's shy but
maybe there's a lot more going on
beneath the surface right sometimes
you'll spend a lot of time with her and
you'll realize it's just there it's a
puddle the shuttle just there's nothing
there and yeah she's quiet because she's
literally got nothing to say you speak
from experience
yeah 100 yeah yeah and but not sexually
100% sexual right this is the title of
to be honest I think we just found our
next t-shirt although I'm a hundred
percent up for being sexual wearing or
being sexual on a t-shirt there is gonna
be one Lassiter who thinks that's a
hilarious T when she comes up the year
that she goes y'all right there in
Australia she's Jamaican yeah I'm
worried that if I were to try something
try anything she would push me away new
shine nah nah nah
the thing is you saw her on drunk yeah
she's definitely into you something
respectful yet sexual here's a good one
short sharp to the point what's the
guy's name it will call him straight no
chaser Alistair Alistair good similar
was near missing it not know or maybe it
is pretty much been a two-year
relationship and I've been broken up and
I just broke up with her three days
after breaking up she [__] one of my
lacy who is it downgrade so I [__] his
ex oh the question I'm asking is do I
beat seven shades of [__] out of him no
because you [__] his ex and nobody did
that as an after is an aftermath of what
actually went out
my opinion if he gets a bit cocky about
it and he starts trying to wage all
about it then he was obviously not a
very good me in which case give him a
slap however she's not on me what is he
he's not me he's a dick [__] I'm off
don't I'm not being funny but three days
after you've come out of relationship
your myths snaked in there like a
[__] like a rat up a drainpipe that
is not a myth
so as far as up to MIT you haven't
gotten it we've got a book we've just
been written
I mean how as much as this one's from
Robbie
it says no I'm not joking it says call
me Robbie yeah I didn't think that is
genuine hi my name is but call me Robbie
basically I was with this girl called
her Sarah probably is a real name as
this could be one of the cuz there's so
much Roy but now I've sort of skimmed it
for about a year in three months when we
got together it was all the mint all
right phrase I'm sorry mint all the mint
I this is hashtag honeymoon period all
the mint honeymoon period as everyone
said the honeymoon period is the best
and that seemed to last for longer than
I expected but then about six seven
months down the line she cheated on me
nekton with her guy best mate while she
was in out in her town best friend boys
oh he's just a friend
he's the one who who saw them not to
worry about right
classic is it plus it yeah classic do
you think it's good to only have one
person you're close with in my
experience whenever a girl has had a boy
best friend who was straight the minute
there was a hint of an opportunity that
boy best friend will move in you know I
mean right into the house move in for
the kill Wow yeah do you know do you
think that's a trust thing like what do
you feel these are not the tunas doesn't
he's looking for the can I just read the
rest of this because I don't usually get
the readers I was obviously distraught
didn't speak to her for a couple of days
then we got back together then she broke
up with me because argue too much then
not
delia sure when I got pissed and nekton
with another lad - to your to her
audacity I got back with her again
it literally is not it's clearly that's
not her audacity that's your stupidity
er basically MIT and after a while so
slightly forget it happened
oh god I doing this awful [__] my God
he's actually used the word suicidal I
started to feel suicidal I'm shut up me
it will you so I thought the best option
was to get out of there because
sometimes you need who did it not just
that Sarah God or my team it literally
what the [__] light like carries poor
in his heart I hear I'm not a nobody
sad no but you know it is what is it
Robbie right sometimes in life you just
need to hold my own
you know we all become a little bit
pathetic right right I've been there
I've had a girlfriend before who was
taking the piss alright and I didn't
want to admit it to myself
you never do but just taking the piss
and you're coming pathetic hi just get
remaining you just get rid of it can be
quite humiliating Robbie it can be quite
humiliate goodnight sweetheart right it
can be quite a humiliating process to be
cheated on couldn't it if someone cheats
on you it could be sort of very painful
where and then if you get back with them
there's obviously a power dynamic where
where you know they could leave at any
point do you know what I mean well it
depends on how you think about things
put yeah but I mean I'm just saying I
can see what you're trying to say like a
fool and they feel like I've been made a
fool out of here but then you think Lisa
I love that person too much to let them
go so I'm gonna allow them to keep on
doing it good point all right this one's
entitled not a dating question oh I do
my name is I what was his name his name
is TJ Tyrone Tyrone well we can
guarantee his name begins with T did you
yeah yeah don't see those much anymore
you can still find them pretty good
field why say geojo Jeanie the old Sir
George or Jeannie yeah so all right
Tyrone Nazi soon and you can call me and
you can call me that if you'd like oh we
can call me as real name his name is
trim trim on the tresses round him okay
developer a couple years have got a
super favorite team in action yep
and that would be Aston Villa being
terrible here I'm from Norway so I
convinced the family to go on a
Christmas vacation to England so I could
see the game with my dad that's a lovely
idea mo so do they played man United and
the game ended one all good good result
for Villa and Villa actually played
pretty well it was the best football
experience I've ever had
anyways a few days later at the
Christmas gathering and my grandfather's
house
I found myself I found my first true
Jordi video where you talked about the
game that was late 2014 and I've been a
subscriber since I'm a nostalgic guy and
I like a little dig in the past so I was
recently looking for that video I can't
find it so my questions are have you
deleted that video if so why and are
there other videos you've deleted if so
why I might have gotten rid of some ones
that I thought which is bollocks
yes like reviews have yeah because back
in the day I was sort of like fighting
me I didn't understand YouTube very well
so I just sit there on the couch and
talk to me come rub it you know what I
mean and I was a bit bored of those
videos now I didn't delete that many
though I think I'd I think maybe like 20
or something like that Wow
but they're all the same you know I mean
QPR vs Liverpool review you reviewed
them no I'm not saying I did but like
some of them are probably just watch
match of the day I just want to say keep
your [__] pretty much I've got a good
one multiple breakups this one the last
one cuz you get a new jacket no just
what's up lads don't have fun of the
podcast keep killing it yeah will do so
I was with this girl for a year and a
half seventeen years old
heads up and I've broken up before and
got back together and things of were
good again we then broke up again
because I wasn't making enough effort
she then saw another lad and slept
because I wasn't looking and look pepper
so you were giving her enough attention
I see you're really passive-aggressive
or he's really we [__] sick of it man
slept with him all women want his
[__] attention non-stop but she said
it was a rebound
brilliant i sat with a guy oh yeah
that's how great I don't think I wanna
get with you
don't worry was only rebound Oh fine
this time when we got back together she
left me after a week because she said
she thought she still loved me but then
realized her over a weekend she didn't
because I went on oh I went to I went to
full-on to fast so he sort of he went
you know Rosie is try the [__] the
kind of girl you think that guys do when
they [__] up they go our bio roses
I'll post on Instagram I'll you know all
these things where they go oh my god
I've got a keeper and then they sort of
you know and then is basically make
themselves look with Bora busted they
were before hunt yeah she already
started talking to somebody else I can't
stop thinking about her and I feel the
said the new Leonardo DiCaprio film with
them yeah I feel pretty sure that isn't
the correct use of it but that's good
showing it you showing a lack of respect
for some weird being around the
irreverent ones and not good enough and
insecure about myself well when you use
misused words and sentences you will
where do I go from here probably do a
dictionary Cheers
let's also Lawrence you've inspired
oh is this the use of the way to
Reverend Matt is it really took the
other part that is never said thank you
for inspiring me to go to university
[Laughter]
hashtag irreverence this is the shittest
best podcast we've ever done oh so sorry
Reverend over though honestly if it's
imagine someone's like this is the first
true Geordie pardon yes yes they do yes
what would you say to an irreverent guy
like that I'm sorry we love so much at
your joke and I'm glad I it if you're
gonna go to your media University tell
me which one email me mail at laws cast
calm and let me know the just good look
at university good luck good look I hope
you had a lesson in irreverent time and
also thanks for making Lords love so
much a feeling it a little bit
irreverent today as there any girls can
we have any good I wish girls would
centers epi Paul news
Tom jarred lamps his named lamps
Carlitos pin my girlfriend wants to do
annual football Darby's really wit was
my government I'll put that one on my
girlfriend wants to do anal what's the
name for this guy we'll call him Lenny
Leonard his name when I had to listen to
the last one that really made me laugh
the way you said Leonard yeah I don't
know why just Korea I'm 18 years old and
you can say my real name thank God
because we just gave it away anyway
Leonard his name's Lambs Lenny his name
is literally lamb lat Oh Lance Lance but
he's misspelt it
miss its own name his name's Lance Lenny
but he's misspelled his name lamps I
just started University and I met my
girlfriend at uni my girlfriend of just
two weeks asked me to do anal with her
the other day and I didn't know what to
say obviously being at uni has meant
we're doing we've done filthy things
whilst being hammered but not anal don't
mean have you really wanted to do it
yeah she wants to do anal whilst we're
not drunk the only reason I didn't want
to do a nose because I'm really scared
of getting [__] all on my [__] yeah do I
tell her I don't want to do it because I
don't want [__] on my [__] and it's grim
or do I just suck it up definitely don't
do that and do her from behind so I
don't look like a [__] I took a few
different things here thanks sort of
star you know just man up and [__] her
up the arse is the first thing I would
say brilliant especially if I mean you
know lucky you are to have a girl that
wants that you [__] [__] really
secondly if you genuinely can't handle
[__] or you're worried about it which
usually and there are exceptions but
usually you'll be fine
there are other things that you can do
she can do SH shove one of those little
water pockets up a bum and squirt it out
and clean yourself out before you do it
there's an option have you ever made
someone do you know I haven't because I
couldn't give a [__] about a bit of dirt
right but I mean like I said usually
it's never a problem anyway but and also
for Christ's sake bring the loop because
yeah share will there's a lot another
will be a lot nicer for you but easier
for her as well
what does Lube do just for people you
don't know what well obviously in a
[__] it's gonna produce its own Lube
but an ass who won't do that I mean you
can you spit as well but it's just a lot
easier with Lube to be honest with you
you ever use spit yep did it work yep
yeah quite a good lubricant yep the
bottle what I like about the bottle huh
on a woman is it sort of it's tight
right
you know I mean around that bit on the
entrance so you can sort of use that a1
to yourself off right but she's actually
quite literally what sex is no but it's
a different type because obviously in a
plunge it's sort of like when you're in
there it's like a quite a smooth feeling
whereas the bottle just has to be very
very tight around the entrance right
channel I mean so you're saying do it
enjoy it and Reville Reville enjoy enjoy
yourself and stop worrying about [__]
and it is a bit like that one year
younger but like the more you do it the
less you'll care and I mean you have a
shower afterwards general I mean maybe
the great advice would be mix the two
yeah a lot of people do like a bit of
the old anal in the shower
really laughs oh is that a big is that
anything you like no me personally I'll
just do shower afterwards but yeah I've
done that before do you run away going
ooh ooh ooh whack one loss and Brian my
name's Andrew yep you can use my mind
you Morrison from his name he's from
desk foot he's in a predicament I'm in a
bit of a predicament two months ago I
started uni without a girlfriend now I'm
in a relationship I don't want to be in
stupid I've got two options dumper or
stay with her out of sympathy
don't stay without our sympathy moving
or a couple of Andrews
yes quit honestly put a bullet and not
literally but just put a bullet in the
relationship kill it this one's entitled
strong to even stop that just say is ray
okay you can call me Bob right
struggling to even progress of going
after crush love the podcast you can
call me Bob whenever I seem to have some
interest in a girl I always seem to
struggle with making a move or any kind
yeah or any kind of show that I have or
basically he did not show interest how
does he tell girls that he's interested
in starting it just our conversations
isn't it just but don't be too awkward
about it if you're a bit of an awkward
[__] I try and act like just throw it in
there do not smile initially when you
got the go-ahead if she smiles but start
a conversation yeah you know I mean it's
I don't know how lads find this so hard
your aim general because I'm always
being a chatty bastard deal closings not
easy
what's it what do you what's a deal so
what I mean is there's the stages isn't
there and I haven't really thought about
this but you know there's there's the
entrance point of the conversation hi
there's the hello hello you start
talking then there's the point where you
sort of recognized will you do that in
the bubble you go over and sort of go
hello I'd literally walk hello I'm Brian
hello
Brian here back for it what's going on
so if you're in a bar the easiest thing
usually is to try and stand at the bar
where people are serving drinks so there
isn't cool no but like because you're
not then literally going over to her
directly
you both happen to be doing the same
thing at the same time yeah didn't see
you there and get you the drink do you
want anything
yeah yeah maybe just do it and then she
goes oh yeah that'd be really nice I've
got a whole table over there you go
don't worry about it it's fine well I
love champagne yeah your friends seem
fine bottles
yeah you fact your friend [__] you seem
to be shouting over there I I I think
you should go back and tell them to [__]
off you said that happens so this is
three stages there's the like grief
entrance yep
anger no so hello exile loads there's
the middle which is three you then work
out at some point do I actually have a
[__] chance yeah is she interested
is she reciprocating is a body language
telling you she because a lot of girls
just like attention and they like buying
drinks for us so there may be a little
bit like I'll just shut this [__]
loser you do have to look at where the
cash points pay a note you know what I
mean you have to look at that and we've
all had it done where losses sort of
just being friendly and you can't really
work out whether this is for real honor
and at some point you're gonna have to
go out on a limb to find out whether or
not she's really interested so he's you
know you drop a little flirty like drops
flourishing yeah and she and if she
laughs in goes oh well maybe you should
find out then you're like kinda yeah and
and at that point it's at the case of
closing the deal
and that really is that uses that sort
of like a phone number I mean yeah
pretty much or or if you feel like your
looks really and just go in for the kill
that night yeah you just sort of say oh
well maybe we should and my my place
afterwards because there's a lot of
[__] gonna stay out all night I don't
know if you want to I didn't yeah I've
really and then you've got your drinking
your hand you've got her drinking and
you go shall we
and then you both go over and just sort
of chat for a little while maybe you're
in the corner the only reason I started
podcast reviews because you make me
laugh more than any [__] me like
everyone thinks it was genius how
different the arm like not really he
just makes his love I was gonna spend a
lot of time over someone's gonna make me
[__] a lot of time I'm literally in
such a bad mood today and I'm still
offered me [__] good anyway
good shooter do any mods I don't know I
definitely said that was good fine a lot
of advice on women relationship no this
has been a short podcast we probably
edit through this right right down to be
honest with you because half of it was
me sitting up in a packet of crisps
laying down in the back out of brick in
the middle I don't know if you caught
that the funny thing is we might even
put a little bit about a nun site in for
us there for a minute I'll leave the
link in the description below for him
the least I can do finally yeah thanks
for cheering us up lads because I'm
pretty pissed off at the moment and and
thanks to all you lot for all the nice
comments you've probably left of what
you feel about your tea if you haven't
then fine just don't lying far for many
irreverent we've got a sponsor I cook
response us choral thanks to them yeah
Harry's calm / true Geordie people are
always asking us
yeah I'm sure Connell added this as if
it was seamless people were always
asking us
how'd you get such a great shaped beard
Unser's to see him harry's calm / true
Geordie where you lot can get array as a
kit for just 395 deliberately a dog we
all know how much to charge for all
these over price razors out it's a joke
Mayo need you get lovely box shaving
foam all of that and also you can get
that the link will be in the description
below if I remember hopefully I will if
not harrys.com slash true job they
really do offer great prices and
anything else I need to say just
generally be flexible and transparent
anyway so yeah on dears we I'm not
feeling great you lot all those chairs
up so thank you for coming to the
channel once again and following us on
Twitter and all the things you do our
and all the people who retweet when I
try and get guests unsuccessfully thanks
for your efforts please thanks for your
efforts please please keep doing very
Adams should we finish the podcast by
doing a high five and Konkan
freeze-frame it and then like sort of so
military Geordi mean it can't ready okay
look into the middle camera ready
there's the moving one ready three two
one freedom okay free dump that's
thought that wasn't a very good one okay
ready
okay free
[Music]
why we see in freedom subscribe thanks
for watchin must say as they're--they
liked the video yeah